marc lavoine avec les akènes alors cet
album donc votre huitième album marc
lavoine est réédité dans un coffret où
il ya le cd puis un dvd à ça c'est joué
que la première fois où on met un non je
ne sais pas si c'est la première cage
jamais vu ça donc dans les bd il ya un
making of de l'enregistrement de l'album
et puis un certain nombre de cubains t4
les quatre clips de le week-end
ça me fait rire allons-y et mme bachelet
acajou d'un sourire sur rien de
l'aviateur alors voilà non marc lavoine
tourné en france un bientôt
et puis l'olympia du 21 au 25 janvier
c'est important surtout pour vous parce
que vous avez été ouvrira la pia donc
maintenant faire quatre jours à
l'olympia succès l'état écoute c'est
vraiment incroyable j'ai toujours habité
dans le quartier de l'intérêt c'était
pratique la partie bien comme je conduis
pas de voiture moi je méritais dans les
endroits c'est central de la campagne
et puis c'est vrai que c'est eux qui
m'ont logé nourri blanchi pendant trois
ou quatre ans mais accueillie et que ma
troupe de théâtre dans laquelle je
bossais nous avait prêté la salle de
billard en place allait bien au dessus
de l'ain vient ensuite c'est eux qui
m'ont envoyé aux éditions du rideau
rouge qui m'ont fait passer des
auditions et serge rousseau à l'époque
était le grand agent de deux verres de
depardieu qui est venu seul
m'auditionner à l'olympia et puis vont
ils m'ont présenté les producteurs avec
lesquels je suis toujours les
compositeurs comme fabrice aboulker ça
je leur dois beaucoup
si je vous dois le duo est claire keim
grâce à tout le monde en parle à
l'olympia je dois donc marc lavoine à
l'olympia du 21 au 25 janvier
alors juste un mot comme ça vous vous
parrainez marque depuis une douzaine
d'années une association qui s'appelle
le papotin c'est le nom d'un journal
publié par de jeunes handicapés mentaux
ouais je vais vous en dire un mot bah
oui ça fait quinze ans que ces jeunes
écrivent et interviewe des artistes des
artistes d'art contemporain des
comédiens des philosophes et puis bon on
a fait donc une trentaine de numéros et
puis dernièrement c'est vrai que les
hommes politiques se sont intéressés de
près à ce projet parce que c'est une
manière différente de mélanger la
société avec ses exclus et on y perd
beaucoup on ne ne vivent pas avec les
handicapés avec les dents en hiver si on
vit encore très proche et très ensemble
donc c'est avec bertrand delanoë
claude allègre bayrou jacques lang et
puis dernièrement évidemment jacques
chirac qui a accepté de faire une
interview trois heures dans son bureau
avec douze jeunes autistes
ça ça a donné une dynamique une
dimension type différent donc il s'agit
maintenant de faire peut-être un livre
aux chevreuils
décidément ce marc lavoine l'impact des
beaux yeux bleus et bleues que le bleu
de ses yeux
je ne vois rien de mieux mais alors vous
savez marc lavoine que les
téléspectateurs peuvent poser des
questions par mail oui aux invités de
l'émission alors vous sais c'est pas du
baratin j'ai reçu un mail et que c'est
bien marc lavoine vous est désespérant
de gentillesse oui pouvez-vous enfin
dire du mal de quelqu'un
marc catane et fort je sais que pour
vous c'est terrible mais ce que je mets
à votre place
est ce que vous pourriez dire du mal de
quelqu'un vraiment une fois dans votre
vie non je trouve qu'on peut agir contre
les gens qu'on aime pas à dire voter
descendre dans la rue prendre position
travaille dans une association pour
améliorer la vie des gens qu'on aime
contre ce qui ne les regarde pas avec
ses enfants
moi j'ai un enfant qui vit aux états
unis qui métisse
11 septembre ça a été important pour les
gens les blacks aux états unis donc mon
fils par exemple leur donner une
éducation pour essayer de les chansons
aussi l'attitude qu'on a un parti dit du
mal de quelqu'un je gère le dire c'était
parce que le mmo vision fruit lui en
dire du mal de l'extrême droite ou dire
du mal des les antisémites et anti gay
mais je fais dans mes chansons
j'écris c'est ça la france pour sage une
chanson sur la prostitution pour ça avec
ravalec fait des films sur la guerre
d'espagne pour démonter les mécanismes
fasciste je m'inscris dans des avec des
gens je crois que c'est important comme
les restos du coeur une personne c'est
plusieurs personnes qui agissent contre
les mauvaises car je pense que c'est
sans espoir là je suis parti dans un
jugement j'ai fait une caméra je suis
parti dans un truc genre mais part je
vois chez vous des gens comme ça et
manuelles ou quand même je vois l'action
de personnes qui n'ont jamais dit du mal
des autres mais qui ont nom justement
c'est des gens qui adorent et c'est bien
je trouve que leurs actes sont plus
éloquents les discours en discours et
les silences en disent non donc j'y
arriverai pas j'y arriverai pas j'y
arriverai pas
non parce que ça sert à un peu grand
chose dont vous voulez pas dire du match
et franchement je me battrai contre moi
si je devais dire du mal de quelqu'un de
gentil c'est pour ça que je vous demande
ça alors j'ai on passe un peu pour des
imbéciles high yield et abc le re oui
mais non on veut se battre on veut se
battre sérieusement contre des choses
qui nous révolte sans pour ça à dire du
mal bon bah je crois que un mois que
j'ai raclé m'en fous
les
m